[Musique]
pour la rose elle-même on peut dire
qu'on a consacré à peu près 2 mois de
l'activité de l'atelier travailler
dessus donc voilà là on la
repose et ensuite il va y avoir la
serrerie qui va être posée à l'extérieur
pour accueillir la double verrière et on
a conur de de chez de beitus qui doit
venir ensuite poser sa double verrière
et là la restauration sera vraiment
finie
un problème de mon
côté c'est trop
bien je c
ou
ça y est c'est le dernier jour et on
termine juste les derniers finition et
les derniers badigons les derniers jours
ils sont toujours chargés de beaucoup
petites choses beaucoup beaucoup je suis
content de terminer parce que après
presque 5 ans c'est fait
longue